hi I'm Chet Haase an engineer on the
Android team at Google I work on
graphics and animation but today I'm
going to talk about something a little
bit different a little bit of animation
but it's more about doing things wrong
so this is the first in possibly an
ongoing series which i like to call
you're doing it wrong so the demo I'm
going to show you today this is really
hacked up as many of my demos are and
very obvious and and you may not do
things exactly this way but these are
examples taken from relapse shipping on
the device where we've seen approaches
like this or like this in a maybe much
more complex and not as obviously bad
way so it's important to sort of take
the the main idea away from it if not
the exact implementation so in
particular I want to look at list view
and the idea that there's a distinction
between the position of items on the
screen and the views that represent the
content in those items and you should
understand those differences very
carefully for the following reason so
let's take a look at the demo which I
call ListView deletion and we've got a
list of cheeses on the screen we can
select several of these and we want to
select the ones that we're getting rid
of so we click the delete selected they
fade out so that's the animation part of
this thing they fade out and then we
remove them from the adapter and the
list view updates and all things are
wonderful but what happens if we select
a few of these and then we scroll down
and okay we'll go ahead and run the
deletion okay let's run that one again
if I could slow mo this I would notice
that there are things fading out on the
screen that had nothing to do with the
ones that are checked in fact if I
scroll all the checked ones off the
screen nothing should fade out because
none of these items are actually
selected right so they shouldn't be
removed but they are but actually the
content that's the content of the items
themselves is not being deleted what's
being deleted are the views right so we
fade out the view and then we delete the
items well the items that are being
deleted or not the view that are being
faded out so what's going on so there's
a concept in the list view of view
recycling this is done because you can
have lists
views of enormous size with tons of
views in them and we don't want to
instantiate all of those things and have
them persistent in the state of the
activity at all times and we don't want
to have to update all this stuff every
time we redraw the ListView so instead
we have active views for the items that
are on the screen at the time and as
view scroll off those views get recycled
and used for other content on the screen
it's very nice it makes a list view very
smooth to fleeing into scroll and to
interact with however it means that if
you are assuming things about the
specific views that are being used in a
listview you're doing it wrong there
there it's important to understand that
list view you should really think of it
as a holder of content and you need to
really interact with that content in
terms of the adapter directly and not
necessarily the views on the screen or
else you at least need to know what
you're doing so let's take a look at the
code and see what the application is
doing wrong so we have this list view
deletion class we create this arraylist
holding this large list of cheese is
terribly interesting content and then we
have this set onclicklistener for the
delete button so when you click the
button it figures out what to delete and
runs animations in Ruby removes things
appropriately oh and then there's some
code down here where when you actually
checked on these things so we can take a
look at that on item click listener for
the checkbox it basically adds these
views to this list of checked views
there so we track that now this is kind
of the hack part of the demo where we're
actually tracking you know the views
that are actually being deleted for the
purposes of the demo so we go through
here and we go through the the checked
items of the list view and this is the
default code which is bad which is okay
we're not this checkbox to to control
the behavior is not currently check so
we're going to we're going to run the
code that we thought was obvious and
we're going to simply remove we're going
to fade out views and remove them so
first of all we're going to post this a
delayed thing to actually remove it from
the adapter after the fade animation is
done we know that the animation is going
to take 300 milliseconds the actual
animation is run down here where we
iterate through the checked views list
and for each one of those we grab the
view
that was checked and we run a animation
on it this is using the view property
animator API which was introduced in the
32 release so we say animate the Alpha
property to 0 and when you finish let's
restore the Alpha property because
that's good practice otherwise this
thing stays invisible so all what that
looks good except for the part where if
you scrolled off the screen that view
got recycled and reused by completely
different content so now we're going to
fade out the view which has nothing to
do with the content that was checked
which is now sitting off the screen bad
way to go if we go back and look at the
demo again and we say use positions
instead of use views and we check a
bunch of things on here and then we run
this thing well of course it does the
right thing when they're on the screen
anyway but if we scroll these things off
the screen then it fades out only the
ones that are actually selected that are
on the screen and that logic works as
follows so in here we go into the else
clause first of all we clear this thing
so that we're not going to run
animations on these because we have a
different way of managing our animations
in this approach we get the position on
the screen so we can get the first
visible position and then everything
after that is numbered after that
position so we can say okay this is the
first visible position and then we
iterate through so this is the number of
checked items so we're actually
iterating through the list view items
here so we can get the position of the
list view item itself the position of
the first visible position and then
figure out whether that thing is
actually on screen and if it's not on
screen don't run an animation at all
just remove the thing in fact we should
remove it after we're done so that it
doesn't blink the list and move stuff
around at the time but we basically use
that as a trigger to determine whether
it's on screen there for running
animation on the thing or it's off
screen don't bother with the animation
just remove it when all the animations
are done so if it is on screen then we
do a similar animation as we did before
we animate the Alpha property on that
view with an end action to restore alpha
and after we've restored alpha then we
remove it from the adapter so all the
animation code before was good what
wasn't good was that we were using a
view that was determined at checked I'm
not at the time when we were actually
telling the system to delete and we knew
what was actually on the screen at the
time so the takeaway here is be aware of
the position of your items on the screen
be aware that your views can be recycled
and be aware that there is a really
large disconnect potentially between
those positions and the views and the
data underneath that the views happen to
be displaying at any point in time so
thanks